we dunk on somebody it's it's it's
almost like you took this whole draft in
1984 it's getting real now you know
you're there
when my name you know was announced just
all of that fear feeling of being scared
all that just sort of went away and now
I kept thinking you know fall as you're
walking up there but I have a pretty big
head so I don't wear a lot of hats cuz
not a lot of hats fit and so thankfully
they even knew my head size or they had
an adjustable whatever but it fit that
was where I wanted to be that's that's
the team the city the organization I
want to be a part of you know I got the
label mr. nice guy I think people
sometimes do mistake being nice for
kindness for weakness and so I came out
of the gates fast like I came out late
and the way I played going to the basket
the game was more physical trying to go
and dunking somebody I like to say it's
like I out-of-body experience
it's mano a mano I guess it's like
getting in the ring with somebody so you
trying to punch somebody face you just
can't go up there saw okay nice you're
going up there to destroy your opponent
and then I ended up dunking on you yeah
it's like you took a piece of their
heart like a piece of your soul I guess
taking souls is kind of fun I was was
home in the DC area to meet with Fela
just left there saying that this is
where I want to be it feels right it is
right sign on the dotted line let's get
going that's how it all kind of came
about this is the Fela spoiler Grant
Hill draft day edition before my
signature shoe was ready my rookie year
I wore the field of sport so when I got
off to that hot start right out the gate
I was wearing this shoe right here to be
able to relaunch that 25 years later
it's something that we're really really
excited about this little flat right
here the print here is the print that I
had on my tie
during my draft very nineties but I
think that's a cool little feature this
shoe brings back a lot of one
for memories for me I'm grateful and I'm
honored I'm humbled but also really
excited to see it be a part of what Fela
has in store for the future